well
i'm pleased today to be talking to ben
shapiro
ben i think really doesn't need an
introduction at least not to most of you
who will be there watching or listening
to this
given that he's now one of the most
recognized individuals on the american
political
journalism scene in any case
ben's an american lawyer writer
journalist and political commentator
he's written 10 books the latest of
which is the right side of history
how reason and moral purpose made the
west great
which has become a number one new york
times bestseller
i think it's at number four right now i
think ben
just mentioned to me that he sold about
150 000 copies since it was released and
that was only a couple of weeks ago so
that's going very well he became the
youngest nationally syndicated column in
the u.s
at age 17. he's also one of the most
recognized current commentators on the
new media
youtube and podcasts serves as
editor-in-chief for the daily wire which
he founded
and is the host of the ben shapiro show
which runs daily on podcasted radio
he's managed to transform himself into a
one-man media empire and
it's quite the accomplishment and
he's also an extraordinarily interesting
person i think to follow
to watch in his interactions with people
publicly because he's an unbelievably
sharp debater and
one of the fastest verbally fastest
people that i've ever met
so um it's good we're going to talk
about his book today
that's the right side of history how
reason and moral purpose
made the west great and i can tell you
right there there's
four reasons for social justice types to
be irritated just at the
just at that what would you call it the
the daring of the title so let's talk
about it
tell me about your book tell me where
you wrote it
the the reason that i wrote the book is
because in 2016
i kind of looked around and for the
record i didn't vote for either of the
presidential candidates in 2016 neither
of them met my minimum standard to be
president based on the evidence
and i i looked at the sort of attitude
that had changed in america it used to
be
that we'd have elections and they were
really fraught people were angry each
other people were upset each other but
the rage seemed
almost out of control in the last
election cycle in 2016.
i was personally receiving enormous
number of death threats
for my positions on on politics i was
receiving
enormous amount of hatred from the the
alt-right uh
i know that there are some of the media
like the economists who have falsely
labeled me all right which is hilarious
to me since i've been their most
outspoken critic for several years at
this point
and that year in 2016 i was their number
one target according to the
anti-defamation league
and well maybe you're just one of those
guys that's tricky enough to be
part of the alt-right and also their
enemy right i
you know we jews man yeah yeah well you
guys are you're
sneaky you're suffering nefarious it's
all about the benjamins
yeah in any case i was receiving all
sorts of blowback for that at the same
time i was going on college campuses and
being protested to the extent that i was
requiring hundreds of police officers to
accompany me
on at certain college campuses and i
started to think
there is something deeply wrong here and
it's not just that we are disagreeing
with each other it's that
there's a certain level of hatred and
tribalism that's building up in american
politics
that i hadn't really seen before there
was a feeling like
even back as as late as 2009 that
america was moving in the right
direction
post obama's election there was a
feeling like okay well we have the same
fundamental principles we're trying to
perfect those principles we may disagree
over the ramifications of those
principles some of us may want more
government involvement in health care
some of us want less
some of us may want more regulations in
markets some of us may want less or
redistributionism or
non-redistributionism but the the
fundamental principles things like free
speech
things like the inherent value of the
individual
things like the idea that i'm supposed
to generally respect your right to your
own labor
these these were all things that we sort
of agreed on
and then we were trying to broaden that
out to encompass further groups
and as time moved on it seemed like we
were moving away from
a lot of those fundamental assumptions
you started to see rises in
the opioid epidemic in suicide rates you
started to see a general level of
unhappiness
crop up that was reflected in the
political tribalism i was feeling but
was
reflected more generally as more
generally in
actual lowered life expectancy in the
united states for the first time
in decades and i started to think
there's an actual deeper problem wrong
here than just
we disagree on politics there's
something deeply wrong here we don't
trust our institutions anymore by pull
data
most of us don't know or trust all of
our neighbors
all of this stuff speaks to a
dissolution of the social fabric
so why is that happening what's this and
this is nearly unjustifiable i mean if
you look at us just
from a material prosperity level it's
unjustifiable if you look at us from a
political freedom level it's
unjustifiable
we are the freest most prosperous people
in the history of the world and yet
we're totally pissed off at each other
all the time
and we're filling that that hole with
anger and with
social mobbing on online and with woke
scolding
and and where's all this coming from and
that led me to to
write the book which essentially argues
that we've forgotten the foundations of
our civilization the principles we used
to hold in common have deep roots and
when we forget those roots we tend to
move away from the principles
themselves and this is manifested in
what i think is the great debate over
western civilization right now one side
which says western civilization was
rooted in good
eternal immutable truths that were not
always perfectly realized
and that over time we have we have moved
toward greater realization of
and that's why the west is great that's
why the west has provided material
prosperity to the vast majority of the
globe it's why
80 percent of people have been raised
from abject poverty since 1980
it's why you've seen this this massive
increase
in the number of people who are living
in decent conditions it's also why you
see a rise in democracy a rise in
political liberalism small
small kind of classical liberalism all
of this is the result of the west and so
we ought to thank the west and we got to
look back to the roots and see what is
there worth preserving
and then there's that seems i would say
to be a viewpoint
that would have broadly characterized
both conservatives and
classic liberals as far as i'm concerned
right that's that's right
and then there's the second point of
view and the second point of view has
cropped up
and become very prominent in the west in
the last
couple of decades particularly since the
1960s and that perspective is that
western civilization is really
just a mask for hierarchy that basically
there's a bunch of power hierarchies
and subjugal hierarchies
forcible oppressive hierarchies white
people against black people rich people
against poor people
the powerful against the non-powerful
the one percent against the 99
and all of these institutions things
like the family things like
the things like free speech itself
things like free markets
these are actually just excuses for
domination and subjugation
they're not actual principles we hold to
they're not important principles in fact
those principles have to be rooted out
so that we can have a better humanity
bloom
in the wake of all of this now in my
perspective this takes for granted
all of the prosperity it seems to assume
that the natural state of man is
prosperity and freedom when in fact the
natural state of man
is misery and short life okay so that's
an interesting thing right there that
i've been thinking about quite a bit
it's it's as if the radical left
i mean there's a denial on the radical
left of
let's say biological differences between
men and women
right everything's socioculturally
constructed
that seems to me to be rooted in an even
deeper denial of
biology and nature in a more fundamental
sense i mean
the left worships nature as something
intrinsically positive
you see that reflected in the more
radical forms of environmentalism
and some of the more toxic anti-humanism
that goes along with that like the idea
that we're a cancer on the face of the
planet or that the world would be better
off if there weren't human beings on it
but what seems to not be part of that
which is quite surprising to me
is any recognition that although nature
is
let's call it at least awe-inspiring um
which also includes the positive it's
also now unbelievably deadly force
and the the truth of the matter is that
the natural state of human beings is
privation and want right from birth
and to blame what and what seems to
happen so often on the radical left is
that that's ignored entirely it's as if
the natural state of
human beings is plenty
and delight delight in existence
and that all of the terrible things that
happen to people in their lives are
actually can be laid at the feet of
faulty
social institutions it seems like such a
strange position given that the
evidence that nature is trying to do us
in on a regular basis is
overwhelming i don't know if the if the
left
is so positively inclined in a romantic
manner towards the idea of nature
because that strengthens their position
that all of the pathology
that characterizes the world can be laid
at the feet of
institutions and particularly capitalist
institutions
but it still seems to me to be it's a
strange phenomenon
but it really it's strange and it's and
it's obviously
ignorant but i think that there's
something else that really is is going
on here
the the marxists of today are are
arguing many of them
are arguing that what they're really
wanting is greater shared material
prosperity i don't think that that's
actually what's capturing the minds of
people right now i think what's actually
capturing the minds of people
was the spiritual promise of marxism the
idea that marx
lays out even in the communist manifesto
when he is talking about the
transformation of man i mean
his initial argument is that markets
warp people the people
have become meaner and cruder and ruder
and more terrible
because of markets because they are
self-interested that the markets
emphasize self-interest as opposed to
altruism and therefore if you got rid of
markets
then you could exist in greater peace
and prosperity and plenty
because human beings themselves would
transform so it's not that the system
itself
would create greater material prosperity
it's that in the initial run it probably
would create more privation it's that in
the long run
human beings would be transformed in
their souls by all of this
and then they would feel greater bonds
to the people around them that was the
spiritual promise of marxism i think
that that's
i th at root what what a lot of people
in the west are resonating
okay so so that's that's a hope for
something like uh
well it's almost like a religious
redemption
it's a strange thing too you know i'm
preparing for this debate that i'm going
to have with slavoy zijak on april 19th
and i've been trying to think it through
and one of the things that's really
struck me is that
not only are the solutions that marxist
marxism offers error ridden to say the
least given the historical evidence
and and i just don't see how anybody can
deny that although people certainly do
but that the problem that
the marxist originally identified seems
actually to be vanishing
that i mean as you already pointed out
there's been an
unparalleled increase in material
prosperity
among not only among the rich which
you could complain about if you were
concerned about inequality but among the
poorest people in the world like we have
absolute material privation based on un
standards by 50
between the year 2000 and 2012 and the
cynics say that's because we set the
standard for material privation too
low which is 1.90 a day but if you look
at the curves
that you can generate at levels of and
3.80 cents a day
or seven dollars and sixty cents a day
you see exactly the same thing happening
and you see
rapid increases in economic growth in
sub-saharan africa like you know
seven percent growth rates which are
more or typically characteristics say of
china or india
and and and that's manifested in
unbelievably positive statistical
evidence
such as that suggesting that now the
child mortality rate in
africa is the same as it was in europe
in 1952.
and so the marxists original complaint
was that you know the rich were going to
get richer and the poor were going to
get poorer
and that that would that could be laid
at the feet of capitalism just like the
fact of hierarchy itself could be laid
at the feet of capitalism
and a it's clear that capitalism
although it does produce hierarchical
inequality
just like every other system that we
know of it also produces wealth and that
wealth is actually being very
effectively distributed to the people
you know perhaps not primarily to the
people who most need it
but to the people who most need it in
ways that are truly mattering
and so to me the entire the entire
structure of marxism is is
it's it's an anachronistic the problem
is no longer
appropriately formulated and the
solution tends to be
deadly if counterproductive if not
deadly
so it's it's maybe here here's something
i've been thinking about too
you can tell me what you think about
this you know
some of it still has to do with the
innate
human emotional response to inequality
you know when you walk down the street
and you see a ruined
alcoholic schizophrenic who's obviously
suffering in 50 different dimensions
it's very difficult to feel positive
about the state of humanity in the world
and it's very easy
for a reflexive compassion to take over
and say
well wouldn't it be something if we
could just retool society so that
none of that was necessary it must be
someone's fault it must be something
that we're not doing right and
you know there's some truth in that
because of course our systems could be
better than
they are and and it seems to me
to be that unreflexive compassion
that drives whatever residual
attractiveness
that marxism still has apart also from
the darker possibility which is that
it really does appeal to the jealousy
that's characteristic of people in the
envy
and which manifests itself as hatred for
hierarchy
on the basis that some people are doing
better than me
you know so right i think there's also
there's also
a failure on the part of advocates of
the free market to point out that free
markets are good for what they are good
for meaning that
the the two things that are important to
recognize about free markets one
free markets are there to create a
generalized level of cheaper goods
and better products at cheaper prices
more widely available that's what
markets do and they do it brilliantly
well that doesn't mean that that markets
are there to
take care of the person who is unable to
work i mean that's not something that
markets
are there to do it's something i talk
about in the book the need for a social
fabric
if you want a free market you also have
to have a social fabric that helps pick
people up now
people on the left have said that
government should be the airset's social
fabric the government should pick those
people up
and in large scale cases maybe that
needs to be the case but
usually it was religious communities and
informal social fabrics that actually
filled
those gaps beyond that there is a second
problem and that is i hear a lot of
populists on both left and right
make the statement that we just need to
make markets work for us
and all i can think when i hear that is
you have fundally m you have
fundamentally misunderstood
what a market is so marxism is a set of
values
and then a system of economics crafted
atop the set of values so the set of
values as you've said before
is that equality should trump prosperity
that equality should trump
freedom that equality should trump
everything so if equality trumps
everything
then the only way to make everyone equal
is to turn them into
in indistinguishable widgets controlled
from above until we create an economic
system to do that there are principles
that undergird free markets
free markets are not a human
construction free markets are a
recognition that you are an individual
human being in control of your own labor
that simple understanding means that you
cannot support
any other form of a market now you can
support some form of redistributionism
at the local level
you can try and urge people to be more
moral by giving to their fellow man
but markets themselves are a recognition
of a basic truth that marxism rejects
which is that freedom and individualism
ought to trump
and indeed need to trump the the need
for equality so
the freedom versus equality battle is
very much alive in our time
and because we have such freedom people
tend toward equality i think when
you have well and we should talk about a
little bit about equality too because
there's two important uh there's two
important
modes of equality that are that that
have to be segregated and discussed
separately because people tend to
confuse
equality of opportunity with equality of
outcome
right and i think that it's perfectly
reasonable to be
a free-market champion let's say or at
least an appreciator of
the utility of free markets and to be
strongly in favor of equality of
opportunity
which means that you try to remove
from the market system any impediments
to people
manifesting those talents that would
make them effective and competent
players in the productive market itself
mostly on the basis of the fact that
that's counterproductive for everyone
the individuals but also for everyone
who could be benefiting from their
talent
yeah that's absolutely true and i think
that's inherent in the idea of markets
it's why
when people use terms like crony
capitalism i always think there's no
such thing there's there's
corporate there's corporate corporatism
which is a better description of it
crony capitalism is a self-refuting
proposition capitalism and free markets
are based on exactly what you're talking
about
because again the fundamental principle
is i own my own labor
which means that if you impede my
ability to alienate that labor you are
now interfering
with my labor so free markets are are
predicated
on an idea of equality and rights and
the idea of
every human being made is why i say
there's a judeo-christian heritage to
free markets
every human being made in the in the
image of god which i think is the single
most important sentence written
in in the history of humanity and when
you abandon the the
we we tend to think that these things
naturally occur this is where you get
into the enlightenment argument
enlightenment argument is that you can
just reason your way to these things
well you can reason your way to these
things there are also a lot of other
things you can reason your way to
including communism and fascism the
question is where what are your starting
points what what are the actual
fundamental assumptions that you make
about human beings and the nature of the
world
that you then apply reason to to arrive
at something great
and this is why i'm not a fan of the
the enlightenment view that just if we
start tabularazo we can come up with
exactly the system that we've built
today i don't think that that's either
historically accurate or philosophically
accurate
because we see that human beings reach a
wide variety of conclusions based on
different premises
well it's it's also the case that it it
assumes that reason
in fact in some sense can be complete in
including
its ability to generate its own
comprehensive axioms which can also be
justified on rational grounds
and it's not obvious to me that that's
the case i think that's why the founders
of the declaration of independence were
forced to say
we find these truths to be self-evident
right you have to have a starting point
and this is something that i
do believe that people like stephen
pinker who i have a great amount of
admiration for
um are make an error in their
overvaluation of the enlightenment and
and their devaluation of the historical
uh what the vast historical epochs
that produced the works of imagination
that produced the axioms on which
the enlightenment could originally
emerge and and
you and i seem to agree i think very
precisely on
especially that phrase that you just
used i mean
i think there's two statements
in the in genesis that are of
equivalent importance actually um
one of them maybe there's three one of
them is that
what god used to create order
out of potential and chaos was something
approximating
a process that was characterized by
truth and courage
and so there's a there's an idea there
which is why i think god continually
repeats after he creates day after day
that the creation was good and so the
idea is that if you
face the potential of the world which is
i think something that human beings do
with their consciousness i think that's
what consciousness is for
if you face the world with truth and
courage then what you
generate out of that field of
possibilities is in fact
good even though the price the pr you
may pay a price for the truth in the
short term
it's an act of faith even in some sense
which
reflects that axiomatic presupposition
that
there's nothing that's going to improve
the world more than
forthright confrontation with the
structure of reality and an
attempt to abide by the truth and then
you have that second statement which is
a miraculous statement i believe it's
it's hard to see it as
as anything else um that both men and
women are made in the image of god
we've we've already had god established
as the creator and the creator who
creates in a certain
ethical manner and then that
power or ability or virtue or privilege
or responsibility is transferred to
human beings and it's transferred to men
and women and i also find that actually
quite stunning you know because
there's no shortage of post-modern slash
feminist criticism of the
judeo-christian tradition
claiming that it's fundamentally
oppressive and patriarchal and yet right
at the beginning
you have this incredible statement which
which seems to fly in the face of its
of the anachronistic nature of the
document
stating that it's not just men that are
made in the image of god it's men and
women
and that's and that's it isn't
obvious to me how that conclusion was
reached so long ago
yeah that's exactly right and it's also
important to note that historically
speaking
if you look at surrounding documents
documents from mesopotamia typically
the the actual language that was used
the image of god language is actually
not
unique to the bible that exists in other
cultures but it was always the king who
was made in the image of god
right so the people who are most
powerful who are made in the god
extension of that to all human beings
is a unique moment in in philosophical
history
and as you say the idea that god has
created an orderly universe and that we
have the capacity to act out within that
universe and to
see god from behind so to speak that we
can't necessarily see his face but we
can see sort of the
general outline of what he is intending
and then
another verse from genesis that that i
think is deeply important from the cain
and abel story
the the verse where god says to cain tim
shell that you have the ability
to do better than this right from
stephanie says you know i
why didn't you accept my sacrifice and
god says well it's in your control you
know go out and do something
about it and then of course cain rejects
that and it's
that story is so deep and i think it
really is the story of what's happening
right now well yeah god's reaction
yeah exactly god's reaction to cain is
that
i rejected you because you could do
better
right and that's actually a kind of
compliment even though you know
if you're not offering up the proper
sacrifices and things aren't working out
for you it might not be the kind of
compliment that you want to hear
but it is a testament to the potential
of the human spirit
and so you're making the case in your
book
and and this is the this is an what
would you call an injunction an
encouragement to the enlightenment types
to look to their
axioms and to think hard about how it
could be that
the idea of individual democratic
freedom for example
and all of the wonderful explicit
political uh ideas that came out of the
enlightenment
could have possibly emerged
and i do agree that you have to have
that initial conception of the
individual as sovereign and and that
that sovereignty has to be associated
with something
akin to recognition of divinity
at least in so far as what's regarded as
divine
is regarded as the highest of all
possible values
and it is absolutely surprising
as you pointed out that not only is the
idea of the image of god extended to men
and women but
that it is not explicitly not
the domain of kings um who in fact might
be
more at risk for abandoning their
actions as avatars of god so to speak
than those who are in privation you know
you see that consistently in the old
testament
where the kings are being taken to task
constantly by prophets who do appear to
speak
more in the language of god let's say
and then you see it also in the new
testament with the
with the insistence that the wealthy and
powerful
have impediments to proper ethical
action
that those who are less materially
fortunate might not face
yeah i mean that thematic is is present
obviously in the old testament there's
actually a passage where it's talking
about the sacrifices i believe it's in
the book of leviticus
where it talks about bringing uh
accidental sin
sacrifices and it talks about the common
man it says if you shall sin then you
bring the sacrifice and then it says
with regard to the prince the nazi it
says with regards to the prince
the hebrew word is kaasher it says when
you will sin so
the assumption is that if you have great
power the chances of your sinning are
going to be greater because you are
going to conceive of yourself as higher
than others and this is going to lead
you
down a pretty dark path the the point
with regard to the enlightenment is that
we actually have some counter evidence
of the enlightenment
being awesome all the way through if it
is predicated solely on
reason and not on a historic
understanding
of of these principles and that is the
french enlightenment i mean this was one
of my key points when i was looking at
pinker's book enlightenment now which
again you and i agree on this i have
great enlightenment for pinker i took a
class with him when i was at
harvard law school he did a joint class
with alan dershowitz that was kind of
fun
but pinker goes a 450 page book about
the enlightenment
and he never mentions the french
revolution ones and
i i thought i don't know how that's
historically possible to do
the enlightenment was not just david
hume and adam smith
and the american founding fathers the
enlightenment also was
rousseau and voltaire and robespierre
and it was the and it was the german
progressive enlightenment that had a
real dark side
and it's human reason can lead you to a
lot of different very bad places
the the metaphor that i like to use with
regard to western civilization is that
western civilization is
a suspension bridge and then on one and
it's and it's over a river of as you
would say chaos
and on the one end of the bridge the big
pole is
these fundamental assumptions you have
to make about the nature of the world
that i don't believe could be arrived at
other than through
some form of divine revelation this
would be the judeo-christian tradition
and those principles are things like we
have free choice that's an assumption
you have to make
and is not implicit in scientific
materialism the idea that history has a
progressive nature that you can improve
the world around you again that is not a
that that is reliant on an assumption
you have to make the idea that human
beings
are held to a morality that they
themselves do not subjectively create
out of emotional me
and that is something that you have to
make an assumption about the thing the
idea of objective truth itself is
something you have to make
an assumption about and that's an
assumption that i think can be made most
specifically by the idea that there is a
mind
outside of us that creates that
objective truth and stands behind an
ordered universe
right all of those are assumptions from
judeo christian values i think there's
evidence for
for much of this you know one of the
things that i've been discussing with my
audiences is like
you know it depends obviously on what
you're willing to take as evidence
but it isn't obvious to me at all
that you can establish a functional
relationship with yourself
unless you hold yourself responsible for
your actions
and you regard yourself as a a free
agent
in at least in some regards like
obviously we're not omniscient
omnipresent and omnipotent that's
clearly the case we're subject to
stringent limitations and there are
situations in which our actions
devolve into determinism that's obvious
neurophysiologically it has to be the
way the world works is that once you
execute a decision there comes to a
point where that decision
is manifested in something approximating
a deterministic manner
i think the evidence for that is
overwhelming but that doesn't mean that
when you're looking out into the future
and you're contemplating the many paths
that you could take
that what you do to make your decisions
then
is deterministic in a simple in a simple
manner
i think if that was the case there'd be
no need for consciousness at all
and then i look at how people react to
themselves is we hold ourselves
responsible
despite our own inclination
for the sins that we manifest for the
manners in which we wander off the path
people wake up at four in the morning
and they berate themselves
for the actions they took that they knew
they shouldn't and the
inaction that they manifested when they
knew they should have acted
and if we were masters in our own house
without that central moral compass
there'd be no reason at all for us to
wake up and torture ourselves to death
with our moral
um inequity and then if you have a
friend
or a family member and you insist upon
treating them as if they're
a deterministic agent with no effect on
the future and no responsibility for
their choices
it's actually impossible to have a
relationship with them
you can't even have a relationship with
a two or three year old if you
insist upon infantelizing them in that
manner
and not attributing to them the choice
that enables
valid punishment let's say on the one
hand you've done something wrong and you
need to be held accountable for it
but also valid accomplishment on the
other which is that you've done
something that you didn't have to do
that was voluntary that's deserving of
approbation and reinforcement and
we act that out and and then the next
level of evidence seems to be that
if you found your polity on
propositions other than that that the
sovereignty of the individual
and the responsibility of the individual
the whole thing goes sideways
so rapidly that it's almost
indescribable and it it doesn't just go
sideways it goes sideways and down
and so like i don't know exactly what to
make of that
as a proof you know it's a strange sort
of proof
the proof being that well there doesn't
seem to be any
reasonable way for human beings to
organize their
social interactions at any level of
social organization
without accepting those initial i would
say neo-christian assumptions
this is right and then this is where the
the main debate happens between me and
sam harris because sam will
reason himself to those assumptions and
away from those assumptions and to those
assumptions in a way
he'll use those assumptions in building
other assumptions and i i've said to him
before i feel like you're using bricks
from a house that you just turned tore
down
so you can't really do that and this is
why i say
on the one hand you have to have those
judeo-christian assumptions and those by
the way undergird even the very concept
of reason because the idea of reason
is that you are using a willful process
of thought
in order to convince someone else
predicated on the notion that the other
person's opinion
is valuable and that you shouldn't just
club them over the head and take their
stuff i mean
the reason it has the value of reason
has implicit moral biases and those
moral biases you can't reason your way
to as i said to sam from an evolutionary
biology perspective
there's no reason for reason other than
if you think that maybe you can convince
unless especially in a world of non-mass
communication what is the reason
for reason right in a world that
pre-exists mass communication
what is the reason that you need reason
wouldn't force be more effective for
most of human history it was it was
significantly more effective
than reason certainly it's certainly
what the radicals on the left would
argue even now
i mean and the idea of reason seems to
be predicated so
and that would go along with the idea of
free speech which i think is
also equally um grounded in these
underlying axioms is that you know each
of us as sovereign individuals
have a valid mode of existence
about and there's something unique about
that valid mode of existence
and it's also something that can be
communicated and that
part of the reason for rational
discussion is that
the ability to share that unique and
valuable
element of private experience with
someone else
is salutary but it's also cellular
salutary in a manner that allows for the
mutual spiritual
transformation of both of the people
that are involved in the
discussion and it seems to me that you
can't
if you're pro reason you've already
bought that argument
exactly this is exactly right and so
faith and reason to this
extent are not intention faith
undergirds reason because you have to
make us
fundamental assumptions even to get to
reason and this is why i think
that one of the things that has happened
and it's really unfortunate i discussed
it
in the last chapters of the book is that
when you take away the assumptions that
underground reason reason itself
collapses
in it's not that reason the stains up
here on top of the structure
once the structure falls reason falls
with it too and we return to
our sort of tribal naturalistic roots
that are quite
dangerous this is why i say that you
need jerusalem on one end of the bridge
the other end of that suspension bridge
is reason meaning that we can't be
theocrats we can't look
at fundamentalist religious texts and
take them as
as complete literal as completely
literal
and then hope to develop as a
civilization on the basis of that
complete literalism so you have to look
to
which of these commandments for example
in the torah are directed toward
huma eternal human nature so i would
suggest that commandments that are
directed toward
reigning in certain appetites are
directed toward god's understanding of
human nature
that certain injunctions with regards to
how we behave in the ten commandments
these are predicated on a on an
understanding of human nature
that is truly profound and worthwhile
preserving it's also
worth noting that the story of western
civilization is the expansion
of these principles out from the tribal
and toward a broader range of humanity
and that's why
the book is not just an argument here's
how i interpret the bible and here's why
that's right
it's an argument that historical
development was necessary
after the bible so it is not just that
the bible solves all your problems it's
that
god understands even from a religious
perspective in judaism and i think in
christianity too
that we are going to apply human reason
to these texts that's from a religious
perspective
from a non-religious perspective the
point i'm making is that you have to
take these fundamental assumptions
whether you like them or not
that are religiously rooted and then
apply your reason
to develop from the fundamental
assumptions that we have already
stated and then that tension is what
allows the suspension bridge to
continue to function that doesn't mean
that it it is always equally solid
throughout time it isn't because the
tension sometimes wavers sometimes
reason takes dominance
sometimes judeo-christian values or
judaic biblical literalism
takes dominance and if you bottom line
is you collapse a reason you end up with
theocracy you collapse judeo-christian
values you end up with nihilism it's
sort of the basic argument
okay okay so so so you know one of the
things that
that sam is afraid of and you know
there's some validity in this fear
and i think he tends to apply this more
to is to the
the state of islamic fundamentalism but
the same argument can be made
with the other religious traditions um
you know
uh evangelical christianity for example
maybe orthodox judaism
who knows that the danger is that we'll
take these
revealed truths which differ
and that holding them as absolute
revealed truths will make us parochial
tribal and the consequence of that will
be
all sorts of catastrophe and horror
right and you know
one of the things i learned when i was
studying the old testament
this was very interesting um a jewish
friend of mine norman deutsch sort of
clued me into this because one of the
things he told me was that
christians who emphasized the new
testament
tend to parody the old testament god
to a somewhat unfair degree casting him
as
much more tyrannical in some sense the
god of wrath
justice versus mercy yeah right exactly
exactly so i took that seriously and
especially when i was reading the
abrahamic stories and you know you see
you see throughout the earliest writings
the idea that
in some bizarre sense god can be
bargained with
right and and and so you see that even
in the cain and abel story because
cain actually faces god with his
complaints and says well you know here's
how i look at the world
and god excoriates him because he
believes that he's looking at the world
improperly and i think for good reason
but there is the implication that you
could have a conversation with god and
hypothetically learn something and but
then
it that transforms even more when you
see the the stories that follow so
abraham directly intercedes with god
on on in in favor of sodom
right right because and and he makes a
pretty
what would you say extreme case for
redeeming sodom
which seems to have degenerated into
quite the
into quite the state of hell trying to
entice god into not being
more destructive than necessary if
there's any goodness to be found
and he actually does that successfully
and so that's very interesting so even
though
god is absolute in his judgment in some
fundamental sense
there is this capacity for dialogue
which seems to be
an analogy to the idea that reason and
revelation can coexist
and and and and and bolster each other
in some sort of upward development
well this is exactly right and the idea
of natural law which the seeds
are there in the judeo value system i
think natural law is more fully fleshed
out in sort of greek teleological
sense when they talk about the idea that
the aristotle plato when they talk about
the idea
that you can look at the world around
you and discover the purposes of the
world around you simply by using reason
well in the judaic sense there's the
idea that god
abides by the moral code that he himself
created and you can ask him questions
about it
in fact the very name israel is in in
hebrew it's israel
israel literally means struggle with god
yes yes yes
that was the other thing i was going to
bring up the direct thing i was going to
bring up is that
that there is this and that's a
remarkable
that's a remarkable story that it's
it's it's jacob i always get jacob and
joseph confused
thank you yeah it's jacob on the other
side
exactly exactly on the other side of the
river so he hasn't crossed back to his
homeland right he hasn't returned home
after his hero's journey
he sent his wife and his children and
his belongings
ahead to try to make peace with the
brother that he's seriously betrayed
and and he's had his adventures and
maybe he's learned his lessons
but then he's on the bank river and he's
visited by an angel who appears to be
god
and he wrestles with him all night and
he comes out damaged right which is an
indication that this
it's sort of like the the egyptian idea
when horus encounters
seth and has his eye torn out that
there's some
high probability of damage that if you
encounter the divine even
even in some positive sense but he
wrestles with him all night
and then defeats god apparently
in some sense and and
is allowed to move forward with his
adventure and then he's given this new
name
and the name really struck me when i
started thinking about it because what
it does imply
i think this is such a positive message
and and
i don't know how to reconcile it
precisely with the jewish claim
of of chosenness as a people because
my reading of the of that particular
text seemed to imply that
the chosen people are precisely those
who do in fact
wrestle with god and so that they they
take these ethical questions seriously
they're not um accepting them without
question and without thought because
there's no wrestling then
right but the real morality comes in the
in the struggle between the revelation
and the
and uh and and and the freedom for
thought and choice yeah i mean i think
it's a beautiful idea and one of the
things that's fascinating about that is
if you read the rest of
the book of genesis every time in
genesis somebody's name is changed
because there are several name changes
right
abram becomes abraham sarai becomes
sarah
there are several points at which there
are angels who come and basically change
the name or god changes somebody's name
that's their name going forward when
jacob is re-termed israel he has not
called israel consistently
from there to the end of to his death
he's the the names are used
at different times so sometimes he's
israel and sometimes he's jacob so the
idea there
is that sometimes he is the best version
of himself the version of himself who
struggles with morality who struggles
with god
who tries to come up with proper
solutions and sometimes he's still the
old jacob the old jacob who ran away
from esau
and who served seven years unjustly
under laban
and and all the rest of it so it's
really fascinating one of my favorite
tom unic stories
this has been deeply embedded in judea
tradition for a long time the idea of
struggling
with god and struggling with the
dictates of morality because
part of jewish tradition is of course
the idea of the oral tradition
the idea that we were given a written
document on sinai but then there was an
oral tradition that was also passed
along to moses that was the
interpretation of the written tradition
um which in some ways may be a
backfilled justification
but i i think that there's a fundamental
truth to it
there's there's a segment that i quote
in the book from the talmud it's a
really
amazing story where it's it's part of
these sort of apocryphal stories what
they call the agata in in talmudic
in talmudic parliaments there's there's
a story where
there's a rabbi who is in an argument
with a bunch of other rabbis about a
particular point of halacha
of jewish law and this rabbi is arguing
with these other rabbis the other rabbis
vote one way and he votes the other way
so he loses
and the rabbi who loses says listen i
know i'm right not only do i know i'm
right
if i'm right let the walls of this the
walls of this
the synagogue close in around us the
walls start to lean in
and then the the rabbi say you know what
that's not evidence that that doesn't
show that you're right it just shows
that the walls are closing in
he says well you know if if i'm right
then let the river outside start to flow
backwards so the river starts to flow
backwards and the rabbi's inside says
still not evidence
we're not going to take that he says
well if i'm right let there be a bot
call let there be
the voice of god literally come down
from heaven and say that i'm right
and sure enough a voice from heaven
comes down and says
that he's right and the and the other
members of the
parliament the other members of the
sanhedrin they say to him
you know what none of that counts
because god gave us a rule and the rule
is
that we have a majority rule in this
body right here and so our
interpretation is correct and yours is
wrong it doesn't matter what miracles
you bring
to to show that your side is right and
the conclusion of the story is that
god says one of the angels ask god about
it and god says
my children have defeated me and the
idea is that god is happy about this god
wants us to use
our reason to take those fundamental
principles that he gave us and then
develop those across time that's how you
get development
see you know i would also introduce
i would also interpret this to some
degree from a psychological perspective
you know because
and this this might be far f
fetch speculation but i i don't think
that it precisely is
i mean i do believe that our cognitive
structures our cognitive function
are embedded in narrative and that that
seems to be a right hemisphere function
and that the right hemisphere is the
source of intuitive revelation
now whatever metaphysical implications
that have i
that has i i have no idea i also know
that
you know many religious experiences
seem to be characterized by preferential
activity in the right hemisphere so
there's something very strange going on
in the right hemisphere
and then we have a left hemisphere
that's argumentative and parliamentary
and logical
and obviously in order for us to make
our way in the world we have to have a
continual dialogue between the intuitive
axioms
that are offered to us spontaneously in
our imagination by the right hemisphere
and the left hemisphere who does a
critical analysis and tries to lay that
out in some logical
and and let's say logical and
algorithmic manner
but the left can collapse into a kind of
unthinking tyranny as a consequence of
that and
the right without that corrective can
what would you say
stray too far down imaginative paths and
no longer be
applicable to the to the fundamental
day-to-day problems of the world
so we need that balance and and it is a
strange thing that
we have these two hemispheres which
implies that we need two ways of looking
at the world
and i don't think that it's unreasonable
to look at the relationship between that
and then his necessity for something
like
the revelation of intuition and the
corrective power
of rationality but you can't dispense
with the intuition
it seems to do something like ground you
in the world and to provide you with
your fundamental axioms
i think that's right and by the way that
seems to me how an enormous amount of
scientific discovery takes place as you
people have a flash of intuition and
then it's a question of i mean that's
how you come up with a hypothesis right
when you're they often backfill too
you know like the technical scientific
journal
um outlines how you came to your
hypothesis
through a process of rational deduction
by step right but that isn't what
happens what happens is you have a hunch
of some sort and often i've seen this
especially with intuitive scientists
they have a hunch that actually sounds
irrational
when they first put it forward and
sometimes it takes them months or even
years to
backfill that intuition with the
rationality that's necessary to
communicate
its integrity to other scientists and so
the
the narrative that's written in the
scientific document is actually a kind
of
well it's a kind of formal i wouldn't
call it a deception it's a formalization
but it's also predicated on the
assumption that
it's linear rational thinking that leads
to these
intuitive hypotheses and sometimes
that's the case
especially if it's incremental change
but those major leaps forward
are like the introduction of new
alternative axioms
and then they have to be tested by
rationality
yeah i think that's exactly right i
think that's also the story of history
that you have these intuitive leaps
and yeah there's a history to those
intuitive leaps and you do have to have
both you'd have to understand the
history of those intuitive leaps
and you also have to understand what an
intuitive leap has actually taken place
i think you can make that argument about
revelation i think frankly you can make
that argument maybe about the
enlightenment that
there are some intuitive leaps going on
but those intuitive leaps have a history
and don't exist in the absence of the
backstory
so the intuitive leap and the
enlightenment in large part at least
politically seem to me to be
the the full articulation of the idea
that the human being made in the image
of god
had intrinsic worth that transcended
that which was being allowed
under the feudal system you see that
first i would say in the transformation
of
renaissance art because what you see is
the divine figures
for example mary and christ to take a
single exam
or to take two particular examples start
to remove themselves from their iconic
representation
and become genuine individuals and so
that's uh
that's a bringing down of the divine to
earth but it's also an
elevation of the individual right is
that these were real people they were
like
us and at the same time you see this
spread of the idea that well each
individual is
sovereign and worthwhile and i do think
it's out of that that comes
eventually the powerful anti-slavery
movies
movements and the demand for um
universal um suffrage yeah
this is exactly right i mean and this is
the part where i become
rather perturbed when people suggest
that the the
evils of western civilization are unique
while the goods are universal this is
this is the part of the argument i've
never understood from people
who are highly critical of western
civilization they point out correctly
that western civilization has been
responsible for an immense amount of
evil there's tremendous
racism endemic in western civilization
there's there's religious persecution
obviously there's genocide against you
know
my extended family i mean this sort of
stuff was part of western civilization
it is but here's what makes western
civilization different
all of those things exist in virtually
every other culture throughout the vast
span of time
the good stuff is the part that we don't
have a really good explanation for
the good stuff is the part where we have
to say okay what drove all the good
stuff to happen
because any of it for that matter
because damn unlikely well like one of
the things i can't understand
this is a real mystery to me man and i
can't explain it
except and maybe this is an intuitive
idea
because i haven't laid it out as well as
i might have
but one of the things i cannot
understand is how
any countries escaped absolute
corruption
because most of the countries in the
world are absolutely corrupt the police
are corrupt the politicians are corrupt
the unions are corrupt the corporations
are corrupt
the currency is corrupt the day-to-day
interactions between people are corrupt
and and in the really corrupt countries
the interactions between
family members are corrupt you know so
you get situations like well east
germany which is a bit anachronistic now
where you know one out of three people
were government informers
it's like and corruption is easy man
it's and
it's it's it's the hobbesian way of the
world
but then there's a handful of countries
and i would include japan and south
korea among those
that where corruption isn't the
fundamental rule
where trust is the fundamental rule
right i can't see how that could have
manifested itself
except within the confines of a
religious
belief system that insisted above all
on the enactment of a higher
moral ethic right something outside of
politics something outside of
self-interest
it's a weak argument because i still
don't understand it i don't i don't
see how a country can make that
transition from fundamental corruption
to honesty it's it's an absolute miracle
as far as i'm concerned and
a number of countries have managed that
and they
all almost all are either west
western countries or highly westernized
countries
yeah i mean i i think that's exactly
right and and it's also
when you examine different places on
earth what you see is that
the social fabric is going to decide the
character of the country
and this is why when people start saying
well we should apply nordic solutions in
the united states i say well
is our culture the same as as the nordic
culture because maybe that solution is
not going to work i mean
the the sort of one-size-fits-all
attempt in terms of political policy
to just apply things randomly everywhere
and then assume they will go exactly the
same
is obviously untrue most famously in
sort of the the classical
neoconservative foreign policy
conception that you could plop democracy
down in the middle of the gaza strip and
suddenly
then suddenly everybody would be in
favor of free markets
and and peace with your neighbors and
this sort of institutions
tend to be successful when people
are when people teach their kids the
right things
well while that's also part of the
reason that i made the argument
constantly to harris
and other atheists that i've talked to
that they're judeo-christian whether
they know it or not
right and the reason for that is that
all of their embodied actions presuppose
the judeo-christian ethic
the only thing that isn't
religious about them is their
articulated
post-enlightenment rational
representation of the world
and i do think you see that in harris
quite frequently because
he does believe in evil he doesn't
believe in good
he believes that the proper way of
proceeding in the world is to move from
evil towards good
and and i i can't
you know i've had exactly the same
conversation with sam and and
he it was it's been a bizarre
conversation even on the notion of
objective truth so sam
it's it's kind of weird so you and sam
and i uh i would say that i'm
as a religious person more closely
aligned with sam's vision of what
objective truth is
than your sort of american pragmatist
purse
version of what objective truth is and
with that said i don't know where sam is
getting his version right i'm getting my
version from the idea that god created
an objective truth
that the mind of man can fare it out
from time to time
and sam's version is what like i just
don't i don't understand how
evolutionary biology
results in anything remotely approaching
the idea that an objective truth is
possible
i see evolutionarily beneficial stuff
happening
right that if you if you come up with an
idea that makes your species more likely
to predominate
than you hold by that but that doesn't
make it objectively true it makes it
objectively useful
which is a different thing i also don't
see how it's
a straightforward matter to get from
reliance on evolutionary biology say as
your fundamental way of orienting
yourself with regards to reality in the
world
and something like the primacy of
rationality
and the ability to extract out from that
rationality something
approximating a universal morality i
can't see those these three things
fitting together at all
this is right and even even sam's moral
standard which is generalized human
flourishing
there's a lot of play in those joints i
mean i've i've asked him several times
as he was on my sunday special and i
asked him to define human flourishing
and i was pointing out to him that the
vast majority of human beings disagree
on the very nature of what that term
constitutes
if you if you talk to religious people
about what human flourishing constitutes
they're not going to tell you about all
of the nice stuff they have in their
house they're going to tell you about
their ability to teach the religious
precepts to their kids
if you're talking about human
flourishing on an evolutionary level
then presumably that would assume us
having more kids rather than fewer kids
and in developed countries we have fewer
kids
rather than more kids so what exactly is
the standard for
human flourishing other than sort of
what sam
likes well he seems i mean i think part
of the way that he
um circumvents that problem is that is
by pointing out that it might be
possible for us to agree on what
constitutes
unnecessary human suffering and to work
for the opposite of that like it makes
it kind of right
we agree we agree on cruelty i think
well but the funny thing is too
i'm not sure we even agree on that is
the truth well i'm not sure that we
exactly agree on that either because
it's not like there's been any shortage
of
um high cruelty warrior cultures in the
past
i mean that was certainly the case with
rome right or or cruelty on behalf of a
greater good
right you could easily make the case for
cruelty on behalf of human flourishing i
mean hitler did
it's it's it's an evil case that's the
whole point right that's the
that was the case of communism that you
break a few eggs to make an omelette
that is
the higher human flourishing is the is
the interest of the majority it's not
obvious that that's not rational i mean
one of the things i really liked about
solzhenitsyn's book the gulag
archipelago was that
you know he makes this he makes an
anti-enlightenment case in a very
powerful manner
because he says well look here's four or
five axioms or six or seven axioms
they're derived directly from marxism
and um if you
accept those and then you act rationally
as a consequence of your
those axioms and of course the marxists
would claim that those axioms were
derived by rational means
that all you get is something
approximating all hell breaking loose
and so what seems to be the case is that
there is a necessary set of underlying
axioms
and i do believe they're coded properly
in the judeo-christian ethic
that if you then act upon rationally you
get something approximating
whatever progress we've managed to make
and i think that progress is substantive
yep totally agree and and this is
effectively
the case that i'm making in the book i
think that the big difference we have
right now in civilization is a
difference that was first
articulated i think beautifully by gk
chesterton uh in in his sort of contrast
between left and right his
his analogy and it's a beautiful
metaphor is that you're walking through
a forest
and you come across a wall it's just
this old archaic wall
old stone wall you don't know why it's
there if you're on the left your first
instinct is
i don't know why this wall is here
probably i should tear this wall out
because why is the wall here i don't
know
the person on the right the kind of
conservative or traditional
person the traditionally minded person
their first instinct is
i don't know why this wall is here i'm
gonna go try and find out why the wall
is here
and then maybe i'll think about tearing
it out and that's and
that's the case i'm making i think with
regard to
what our civilization there are
foundational
things in our civilization that maybe
it's possible to remove that particular
django block and everything stands but
i'm not going to pretend that just
because i don't understand
the reason for this particular
revelatory principle that the revelatory
principle isn't
important and undergirding and therefore
a reason and put there by people who are
just as smart as i was there's a certain
arrogance to to people
who are living now that they were much
smarter than people who came before no
it's just that you're standing on those
people's shoulders so you can see a
little bit further but
the truth is that they were probably
seven foot you're probably a four footer
yeah well it's definitely the case that
my intellectual attitude changed
quite substantially when i decided that
i was going to
risk taking the religious text that i
was studying
with some degree of seriousness like and
i came to that through solzhenitsyn and
jung i would say
fundamentally because they made a strong
case for
things let's say they made a strong case
that there were presuppositions
encoded in those narratives in a
dreamlike manner
same way that piaget did that we
couldn't do without
and that we sh we should be very careful
in dispensing with them in that
arrogant rational manner so that you you
treat you start by treating the text
with a certain amount of reverence
and you with a certain amount of
ignorance right it's it's there's
something here that you don't understand
and you should probably assume that it's
worthwhile because it's being
been kept rather than to leap to the
proposition that you and your ignorance
can clearly
see why it's unnecessary yeah
and i think that the greatest impact the
the saddest part of this is that the
greatest impact
in terms of throwing away the the
stories of
of our heritage basically is that that
impact is generally not going to be felt
in the urban centers with people who go
to sam's lectures or listen to his
podcast those people
have a a world view that they have
shaped by listening to
stuff like sam's or or or stephen
pinker's
or richard dawkins and that world view
while i think it may not be fully
coherent
it coheres for them but the problem is
that you apply that to people
whose main draw to to morality is not
going to come from listening to these
particular sources the people who get
their social fabric from churches in the
middle of the country in the united
states
the people who have built a social
fabric along with their neighbors
because they have a commonly oriented
goal
and then you take that away from them
and you offer them go find your own
purpose
good luck with that yes that's right
they're not going to turn into
fully fledged humanistic
positively thinking enlightenment types
merely as a consequence of abandoning
the religious superstitions
is exactly the thing that that the
enlightenment types i think
are naive about it's easier to tear down
than to build up
is is is sort of the way that i put it
to sound you can tear apart my religious
tradition
and you can probably do so in an
entertaining way i mean you do obviously
and then how are you going to build what
exactly are you building yeah
and i can do the same thing to to your
world view but then what am i building
the question is going to be what are the
foundational we're not we're not
standing we're not standing at the
we're not standing on the first floor of
the building we are standing on the top
floor of a building
you can't go with the bottom floor with
jackhammers then expect that the top
story is just gonna
stay there it's not how this works yes
yeah yeah yeah that's exactly
it so all right all right well look
um i promised that i'd let you be at 115
and it's 125 and so i don't want to take
up any more of your time
um i'm very pleased that your book is
doing well
i i hope that it does accomplish what
you
set out to accomplish with it is to make
the case that
it's much more appropriate for us in the
modern world
to continue to to consider
the enlightenment first of all in its
faults as well as its virtues
it's a very important issue but also to
continue
to consider it as a continuation of a
process that started
thousands of years before and that can't
be just casually dismissed
on the presupposition that the
enlightenment was drawn out of a hat by
a magician
you know 400 years ago with no
developmental precursor
i think that's an it's you know the
other thing that's remarkable to me
about that is that
the people so many of the people who are
enlightenment types
like pinker and hitchens and harris are
also evolutionary biologists
and jesus they should know better man
it's like
even people like franz dewall you know
who's been studying chimpanzee behavior
has shown very clearly the evolutionary
origins of a rather profound
proto-morality so even if you're not
looking at this from the perspective of
divine revelation whatever that might be
and that and that's a great mystery
you know because i think often divine
revelation is the revelation of our true
nature to ourselves
and you know that might be
metaphysically mediated god only knows
but there's a lengthy developmental
history
preceding the development of anything
like
fundamental moral assumptions and the
evolutionary biology
seems to support that presupposition
powerfully
and so that's another contradiction in
the enlightenment viewpoint that i just
don't get it's like
well as far as you're concerned as an
evolutionary biologist
everything has a history that should be
marked off in the hundreds of millions
or at least the tens of millions of
years
and yet this radically important
transformation in the manner in which
human beings conducted
themselves well that was just something
that emerged
out of nothing right it's like it's it's
it's it's it's so
funny because it's a it's a uh ex
i don't think that's completely
pronounced yeah yeah yeah it's excellent
argument it's like well we were ignorant
um
feudalistic christians squabbling among
each other
in this superstitious morass and all of
a sudden
out of nowhere in some sense came this
brilliant
new way of looking at the world and i
don't see
how that's in keeping with that deeper
view of history that's necessary
if you're an evolutionary biologist yeah
i
i obviously agree totally with that and
i i find it kind of hilarious a lot of
the presuppositions that are made
are fundamentally at odds with a lot of
the other presuppositions that are that
are that undergird the system of thought
you see you know i was talking to pinker
just recently really like two weeks ago
and i approached this topic you know he
did agree by the way
to have a three-way discussion with you
and i
yeah i mean i i'd totally be interested
in that good so i've talked to the ca
people and we're going to try to set it
up because i think
right i think that would be great and we
could we could
we could see what what you see we'll
have an alt-right festival that's
it we're all that's right that's right
that's the way this is now every
everybody's all right if you haven't oh
yeah man we've been attracting neo-nazis
like
us right two jews and two jews and a
self-helping canadian that's yeah
exactly that's that's where we're at the
forefront of that movement that's for
sure
it would be see because one of the
things that that struck me
so interestingly about pinker the last
time i talked to him was as soon as i
broached the argument that these
enlightenment ideas were
founded in something that looked like a
metaphysical religious narrative
whatever its origins
all he did was point to all the negative
examples of
what religious structures have managed
and
right that seems to me to be such an
unfair argument because
it's an avoidance argument again that's
also stuff that
non-religious structures have created
like that's that's
the question is not why bad stuff
happens in religious society the
question is why good stuff at all
that yes that is the question especially
given that it's
it's inappropriate to conflate
religious structures with tribalism
correct you know especially because you
can
you can look i mean you might want to
blame human evil on the proclivity for
us to
gather together in groups under a
religious
hierarchy but then you're stuck with the
problem of chimpanzees who do exactly
the same thing
with the equivalent degree of brutality
with no religious thinking whatsoever
and so i think it's perfectly reasonable
to point out that religious thinking can
become
a variant of tribalism but it's no more
fair to
to blame human social conflict on
religion than it is to blame the
existence of hierarchy on capitalism
the greatest tribalism that i'm seeing
in today's world has not only nothing to
do with religion but is actively
anti-religion
and the the the greatest tribalism that
i'm seeing right now whether you're
talking about the intersectional left
that creates hierarchies of value based
on your group membership
or whether you're talking about the
white supremacist all right which is
militantly anti-christian
and sees christianity and judaism by
extension as
as a weakness that that
that's pure tribalism white supremacy
has nothing to do
with overarching religious instincts in
fact it says that overarching religious
instinct is is quite bad
one of the great anti-tribal forces in
human history has been the presence of
religion
is the point that robert putnam makes in
bowling alone you know he
presupposed that diversity was our
strength as the as the
nostrum goes and he then found that
ethnic diversity
in a vacuum doesn't actually create
strength it creates
ethnic diversity what he said is the
only two things you get with pure ethnic
diversity are increased protest marches
and increased television watching but
if you have a common perspective if you
have a common purpose a common
reason for being together then ethnic
diversity and experiential diversity is
our strength and it's really great right
you go to a church and you see a diverse
group of people all of whom came from
different places
and they all care for each other and
they're all taking care of each other
and they all have different stories to
tell and enriching stories to tell
that's how you build the society yeah
well they're all striving to play the
same axiomatic game
exactly it's predicated on these
underlying revelatory truths
the the most important of which as you
pointed out is the notion that
human beings are made in the image of
god which
which you know it's one of the things
because i i'm
i'm you know i
i tend never to take a religious view if
i could take a scientific view
i never take a metaphysical view if i
can take a reductionist few
you know it's a form of mental hygiene
in some sense
but there are statements there are
biblical statements that are so
unlikely that it's very difficult for me
to account for them
reductionistically or even biologically
even though i've done my best to do so
and that well the idea that you extract
the best out of
the chaos of potential with truth that's
one man because that is one daring
metaphysical statement
and that requires a tremendous amount of
courage to even attempt
and i do believe that it's true i'm not
sure it's not the most true thing that's
ever been written
but then a close contender would be the
one that you identified which is
well men and women are made in the image
of god
it's like who the hell would have
thought that up
it's such a it's it's it's so
crazily irrational in a sense it flies
in the face of
everything that you see about human
beings or virtually everything that you
see about them
their hierarchical arrangement their
relative weakness their mortality
their their flawed nature their sinful
nature
you know their their their their
innumerable inadequacies
and then to say in spite of all that so
long ago
and and at the beginning of this
civilizing tradition that
well yeah despite all that self-evident
um pathology and radical individual
difference
in power and ability that each of us has
a divine
spark it's like ha
it is an it's an amazing thought and
it's an inspiring thought and i hope
that
at the end of the day that's that's if
we're going to take away one message
from
i think this conversation and in general
if we're going to take one message out
to the world
the idea that you're made in the image
of god and so is everybody else if we
build on that i think we can build
something well that's a that's an
excellent place to end
well thanks so much i really appreciate
it jordan it's really good to talk to
you ben
and good luck with your book and i hope
it has the effect that you're
you're hoping for i hope that we can
that we can make a a strong case
especially with the enlightenment types
and and even the atheists to some degree
that i hope so too because i think that
in the end we can all be on the same
page
but i think they're going to have to
recognize the the value of tradition
just as we respect the value of of
reason great
right awesome stay jordan okay man hey
love to see you